so we are given these two complex
numbers and we want to know what w sub 1
divided by w sub 2 is so pause this
video and see if you can figure that out
all right now let's work through this
together
so the form that they've written this in
it actually makes it
pretty straightforward to spot the
modulus
and the argument of each of these
complex numbers
the modulus of w sub 1 we can see out
here
is equal to 8 and the argument
of w sub 1 we can see is
4 pi over 3 if we're thinking in terms
of radians so 4 pi
over 3 radians and then similarly
for w sub 2 its modulus
is equal to 2 and its
argument is equal to 7
pi over 6.
7 pi
over six now in many videos we have
talked about when you multiply one
complex number by another
you're essentially transforming it so
you are going to scale the modulus of
one by the modulus of the other and
you're going to rotate
the argument of one by the argument of
the other i guess you could say you're
going to add the angles
so another way to think about it is if
you have the modulus of w sub 1
divided by w sub 2 well then you're just
going to
divide these moduli here so this is just
going to be 8
over 2 which is equal to 4 and then the
argument
of w sub 1
over w sub 2. this is you could imagine
you're starting at w
sub 1 and then you are going to rotate
it
clockwise by w sub 2's argument
and so this is going to be 4 pi over 3
minus 7 pi over 6 and let's see what
this is going to be if we have a common
denominator
4 pi over 3 is the same thing as 8 pi
over 6 minus 7 pi
over 6 which is going to be equal to pi
over 6. and so we could write this
the quotient w1
divided by w2 is going to be equal to if
we wanted to write it in this form its
modulus is equal to 4
it's going to be 4 times cosine of pi
over 6 plus i
times sine of pi
over 6. now cosine of pi
over 6 we can figure out pi over 6 is
the same thing as a 30 degree
angle and so the cosine of that is
square root of 3 over 2
square root of 3 over 2 and the sine of
pi
over 6 we know from our 30-60-90
triangles
is going to be one-half so this is
one-half
and so if you distribute this 4 this is
going to be equal to 4 times
square root of 3 over 2 is 2 square
roots of 3
and then 4 times one-half is two so plus
two i and we are done